it was an impressive performance
by jimmy butler now i'm not going where
everybody else was going last night i i
was getting a little annoyed with the
broadcast i kept saying oh they're
missing two of their stars stop it jimmy
butler is their star and he played like
it last night he played like
what he is one of the top 15 players in
the nba he's an all-nba talent
he's a two-way player
he's a guy who uh he plays with with
great energy everybody we talked about
this before everybody is worse off
when jimmy butler leaves you figure out
ooh oh wait a minute he was better than
we thought we really miss him
so he i was glad to see him kind of have
a breakout performance on that stage
last night does not change the way i
feel about the series but i was very
entertained by him he was a handful he
was a handful to stop and i think uh los
angeles the lakers would be ready for
him
in game four they were not ready for him
in game three i don't think
psychologically i don't think they were
ready for this team in game three so can
we look at let's let's let's stay here
for a second before we talk about the
rest of the series let's go back to i
won't stay with last night
so we've seen three 40-point triple
doubles in nba finals history west yep
james and now butler
[Music]
we have never seen
in the nba finals
a 40-point triple double on 70 shooting
so that efficient a 40-point
triple-double by the way shaq and kareem
are the only other cats to give 40 on a
double without shooting a three
okay uh to get i'm sorry to get 40 and i
shoot a three
um i told you the three people have
already had uh 40 point triple doubles
already
never in his nba finals career
by opponents or teammates
has lebron james
ever been outscored out rebounded and
out assisted in a game
i mean it's rare anyway
that
lebron is not the best player on the
floor
yeah um
so i you got to appreciate
you got to appreciate what an explosive
element this jimmy butler situation was
last night okay
i mean that was that was an all-time
performance and i'm glad you talked
about him as a top 15 top 20 type player
that was definitely a recalibration type
game
that's the type of game that makes you
step back because you know what what's
crazy is you can get to 15 fast in the
nba
you know we throw that around always the
top 10 top 15 you get the 15 fast
quieter
right i don't know that a lot of people
necessarily
have viewed jimmy butler i mean for one
this is his first trip to the finals i
don't know that people have viewed jimmy
butler
um
as a a superstar
if you protect the word superstar the
way that most of us do i don't know that
most people have viewed jimmy butler as
a superstar i don't know what casual
people have i'm sure you know astute nba
aficionados do
but i'm not sure that he was a
hands-down superstar before before
before this playoff run and definitely
not before last night that if whether
they win or lose a series jimmy butler
has already won over quite a few people
with this run that he's led the heat on
yeah you know he and this this team this
this personality of this heat team fits
him perfectly if you go back to his
story and he was one of the last guys
draft if not the last guy drafted in the
first round of his class i think he was
30th
the 30th pick in the draft you know out
of marquette so
and those guys and they remember it
from from draft night oh okay i'm kind
of overlooked
i'll remember it and they never forget
it and so even with this free agent
class
we talked about kawhi leonard and paul
george but jimmy butler was a free agent
as well
and he went to miami and nobody said uh
miami that was a great pickup for them
they got jimmy butler he's really going
to turn that that franchise around
coming into the playoffs the team
was kind of dismissed they were a number
five seed in the eastern conference they
beat milwaukee
and people still thought the celtics
were the more talented team at the
beginning of the series
and so
they have that that kind of fits with
that that ethic of who they are and it
just fit right into his story last night
you're missing two guys you're down zip
two
oh okay here come the lakers they're
probably gonna beat you in this game and
they beat you in this game they're gonna
sweep you
and it was a
not only was it a statement game for for
jimmy butler but it was a statement game
for this team overall but this is what i
would say because
what does it say what statement what
what statement did they make the
statement is
don't
don't don't don't ever overlook us
don't ever count us out
don't count us out and don't disrespect
us
so i think a part of that did filter
into the lakers last night
they were convincing in those two wins
over miami
and
maybe they started to think about oh
we're almost out of the bubble let's not
dismiss that
it's quicker you can end this series the
quicker you can get the hell out of
there i'm sure they're ready to leave
everybody's ready to leave hey beat this
team on sunday night go up 3-0 now we're
going to sweep them and we're going to
go home
but this is what and i think
you mentioned lebron he's never been
outscored i've rebounded out assisted
let's face it lebron did not play a
great game last night
that's why i think
as
as impressive as this was for jimmy
butler and miami
i don't think it changes the course of
the series i think the lakers still win
the series i think they win it in five
but they got to get their head right
and if i'm lebron i tell the rest of
these guys
when you look at the miami heat no
matter who's out there
don't just look at jimmy butler imagine
everybody has jimmy butler you'll do a
little photoshop put jimmy butler's head
on on two guys on two starters and on
the other three put on pat riley's head
because that's the personality
of the miami heat i'm talking about
crazy pat riley pat riley uh the guy who
would if you go one pound overweight
he'd find you because he had a little
weight system as a coach so he had
everybody he he put you on the scale
every week and if you're one pound or
two pounds over it's coming out of your
check
i'm talking about the pat riley who's to
do these little trust circles and one
time in a trust circle he put his head
in ice cold water
and waited for somebody to pull him out
and when they did he said oh i knew that
was going to happen see i knew you had
my back he's crazy man pat riley's crazy
patriotic you remember pat riley put out
a statement on danny ainge this isn't a
statement a corporate statement
he told danny
no no no he said shut the f up
in a corporate statement
so this is the personality of the miami
heat if you approach them that way
you'll never take them lightly i think
the lakers
are a really good team i think they're i
think they're better i think they're
much better than miami and they should
win this series